the government is the necessary solution
to a problem and that is us lord knows
what we might do without laws but
there's a problem with government that's
us too
first of all the name means something
cool it means to set a thing up firmly
in place it's actually like the word for
statue just think of this particular
problem
if you're gonna have more than one
person make the law you're gonna have to
have a constitution to describe how
that's done or else you're gonna have
wars all the time about who gets to make
the law the Constitution is an attempt
to organize a form of government that is
as close as possible to what human
beings are like and what they need what
they're like is that they need and they
naturally make laws and what they need
is those laws to be consistently fair
and protect them and also restrain them
from harming one another and since it's
true that both the things that needs
protecting and the danger to it is the
same thing then you have to have some
method of both assembling and granting
power and of restraining power and our
Constitution is the best at that in all
of history and the explanations of it by
the people who wrote it
are the most profound explanations of
that kind in all of human history his
self government possible all of human
history all the kings and monarchs and
aristocracy of history had thought no it
can't be done Aristotle himself is very
skeptical he's not opposed but he's
skeptical about democracy the rule of
the many and so the founders are aware
this is a very hard thing to do indeed
never done in history for a long time
before the Constitution has to be
respected it's the law that gives the
process by which we make all the other
laws
it is the only law really ever passed
directly by the people of the United
States and so the people picked the
Constitution and if you think is I think
that no human being has the right by
nature to govern any other human being
without the consent of the of the
governed then of course you have to
think that the majority has to approve
the government all the time but in you
don't want the majority tampering with
the Constitution all the time and so
they invented a process for the people
to pass the Constitution more or less
directly and then that process passed
away and doesn't exist anymore all you
have to do is go and look at any place
where the law cannot be trusted you
don't want to live anywhere like that
you want to live instead in a place
where your efforts are much less as a
percentage dominated by the job of just
protecting yourself young people long
for this right to use their growing
powers to make for themselves a
significant life that's what you want
and you need good laws for that this
idea that maybe in your mind that you
can if you don't like the place where
you can go you can move somewhere else
that's a fact by the way among the the
countries that still enjoy the rule of
law in the other countries not at all
the problem with government the
government is the solution to a problem
right the necessary solution to a
problem and that is us lord knows what
we might do without laws we would be not
unlikely to take each other stuff for
example but there's a problem with
government that's us too so Madison
wrote
what is government with the profoundest
of all commentaries on human nature if
men were angels no government would be
needed if angels were to govern men
neither internal or external controls on
the government would be necessary why
should we listen to this whole thing
write written for the time of the
horse-and-buggy and it's actually true
George Washington had wooden teeth at
least I think it's true serious people
try to figure out what's right what fits
the if there's a thing that is not
susceptible of change we still are born
in a certain way and then we age you
know and eventually we die and that
happens at a pace that's similar for all
of us right if we're going to remain
human beings then my argument is we
should strive to govern ourselves in the
way indicated by the Constitution the
United States it is fit for things like
us